hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
how the heck are you it's been a whole
week since we last caught up on things
in the world of BOTS night so let's do
what we always do and go over this
week's update if you new round these
parts please think about subscribing the
face reveal is coming at 1 million
subscribers now plant your butt down for
10 minutes slap code a tomorrow in the
shop and let's find all the map changes
in season X week 9 and hell yeah we have
another story theory at the end of the
video so many updates in the last 7 days
but let's start with a brand new point
of interest star e suburbs a quaint
little town currently being constructed
above pleasant park but it's also a rift
zone so there has to be some random
shenanigans in this zone super mario
stars fall from the sky which can be
broken for epic loot the stars continue
to fall all games so this spot is
perfect for lazy people who can't be
bothered searching for chests no here's
the thing about starry suburbs which
would blow your mind this was indeed a
location all the way back in season 0 of
fortnight Battle Royale
it was unnamed back then and had
terrible loot spawned but it was
definitely here
the difference back then though it was a
complete ruin a former town which always
made me wonder what happened before day
one a fortnight and now time travel is
here we can see all those seasons back
and in this dimension the town is
looking damn good whether the town was
never destroyed in the first place or
maybe it was never replaced by the
football stadium in this world and was
given the chance to rebuild over the
last 10 seasons
anyway season zero content hang on I've
got an idea this may be a clue let's
include this in today's theory but now
we have something far more important
than a live event let's look at what
watch is back and better than ever our
little wooden Hobbit has grown into this
gorgeous specimen absolutely beautiful
I'm sure you'll agree this week the
building materials have left and the hut
has gone to Browntown and we all know
once you go Brown you never go back
how does us you get the idea so is this
the end just
the lookout tower is what watch over now
of course not keep the faith season 11
will bring more updates who's with me
comment watch my life if you're with me
here rush of 2.0 what was 2.0 is here
over at the failed rift by the former
spot center another building is
beginning its rise let's get the guesses
in now what will this place become only
ridiculous names please let's look at
this further next week rush of 2.0 so
the central story of the season has been
around the visitor the scientists who I
think is the same person by the way and
though rocket have you kept an eye on
this beast this week because he's gone
and done it he's finished it the alien
erection is perfected it even has a
perfect purple end now he may want to
see a doctor about that
GG mr. scientist later in the week the
thrusters were added for interstellar
travel but today a new problem has
arisen the scanned parts of the brute
mechs have run into a problem some
source of corruption in the robot
systems shown by the skull and
crossbones the X's indicate something is
terminal maybe the mechs are finally
leaving us forever
or maybe the mechs are going to turn on
the scientist or is that corrupted tech
already in the spaceship was this the
reason the rocket failed back in season
4 things are hotting up likely this week
the countdown timers will appear for the
live event which will give us a date and
time what do you think will happen I was
hoping for a new map but now I'm not so
sure what say you
since the last time we met Gotham City
has popped up celebrating 80 years of
Batman if he did pick up the skin I'm
presuming you bought this in moat 2 and
just did this all day yeah me too to go
back to Gotham for a moment did you see
the easter-egg Batarang in the hay-bale
before the roof beacon activated it's an
awesome touch Gotham itself though is
full of nods to Batman culture how many
of these did you spot Batman's parents
were murdered in cold blood and we can
see the exact spot in the alley in the
center of Gotham the pearl necklace
making out the shape of a beef for Bruce
or maybe Batman also have they been left
on the ground for 80 years Batman must
have some serious issues if he walks
past this every day of his life
[Music]
all around the city our Joker references
such as his graffiti from both the movie
and the animated cartoon and most iconic
Lee the VAT he fell into to become the
Joker is here in the factory district
the church from many of Batman's
encounters with the Joker is here too
but I will always remember it from Tim
Burton's Batman from 1989 it's an old
one but it's a good one I recommend it
and then that brings me to the cinema a
very real place in Batman's lineage but
this place is rundown and simultaneously
advertising a brand new film I'm
completely baffled with this one what
could it mean is this a hint to next
season or maybe another movie crossover
later in the year and why the hell is
the carpet from the shining here help me
out with this one if you would what
could this mean
and by the way let's see what Batman's
up to Oh it's spending more time with
mum and dad even in Gotham City family
time is important so I went to visit the
Polar Peak monster to see if there are
any changes here and it got me thinking
have you noticed we've been receiving
all the events in the history of
fortnight season three had the meteor
shower in the sky we now have a
permanent reminder of that season four
had the rocket yep we know that's here
in season 5 the map had new locations
from different worlds
yeah we got that season 6 had Kevin
floating season 7 brothers of the husks
again season 8 brought as the vault and
we have a constant reminder of that with
the Nexus point the only major events
which are yet to be covered this season
are the butterfly event and the final
battle hence why we are here do you
remember the shape of the flowers around
this beast yeah they make up a butterfly
so maybe we should keep an eye on this
location
[Music]
a few things to note before we finish
Kevin continues to move around the map
and edge is closer to the new risky
reels which reminds us we should be
ready for impact could this mean Kevin I
mean there's a perfect parking spot for
Kevin to land just a little lower
and these bunker things do you remember
those big keV could always open one of
those if I'm honest though I just don't
want him to destroy what watch Oh on a
tiny update the grass is growing on the
floating island weird on the ps4 it
isn't is it for you remember the ice
cream truck which fell from granny's
house last week well it was simply so
Batman could have his signal there
instead he has no respect for other
people's property
I wonder what Batman is doing right now
uh yeah family time my bad so I believe
that's everything like usual if I miss
something
please holler at me on Twitter now it's
time for another attempt at a story
theory this time it's about the end try
not to cry watching this one you ready
let's do this what if I told you
season X finished before it started we
believe that the meteor magically stays
frozen in time above our heads when in
fact it has already wiped out dusty and
other areas of the island we thought the
season began with the explosion above
the vault but then why is the OP still
here to understand this we need to look
at the seasons name
season X why not ten this is because X
has three key meanings beyond the number
ten X represents the unknown the
unsolved and ultimately X represents a
secrets but the main use of X throughout
history and science is to represent the
end this is the end of our island what
we believe has taken nine weeks has
actually only taken a millisecond the
scientist is bending time and preparing
the island for its demise we can see
evidence of time slowly moving both of
the meteor and the nexus each have moved
fractions almost invisible to the naked
eye the impossible jump to the factories
is now possible but of course this story
includes so many questions and so little
answers why is the scientists adapting
the island if he knows that this is the
end why are the seven dimensions joining
and why are past events returning there
may be a complex answer or maybe just
maybe it's simple before the end our
guardian angel wants us to celebrate
everything we've experienced taking us
back to season zero for our final week
on these Isles back before turbo
building back before launch pads before
live events back to the start one last
time will this come true I don't know
for certain but these last few days are
a celebration of everything we've been
through so far so thank the bus driver
one last time and cherish the memories
[Music]
Wow this community just makes me so
proud Thank You epic games for two
phenomenal years and ten huge seasons I
can't wait to see what happens next
I'm Adam from Playstation grenade it's
been a pleasure I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]